hello everyone and welcome to one of the
coolest real Lopez games you'll ever see
it was played in 1954 between Grand
Master Miroslav Philip and women
International Master Nina ruskova belska
and here are the old steinage defense
was employed in the game uh ends up uh
in in a really really weird position
after Bishop D7 characters captures and
now Knight to C3 Bishop to E7 was played
and queen to F3 and here comes this
weird Bishop to G5 move and now Pawn to
E5 going after the C6 Pawn she defends
with Ponte D5 but now look at this Ponte
E6 and here she resigns and move 10 as
there's nothing more to be done either
she loses the bishop or she loses this
bishop or queen capture Sun F7 will be
Checkmate and there's no defense against
all of this if you try Bishop captures
then just Knight captures and you open
up this diagonal towards the black king
this comes with check once you block you
pick up the bishop and you are now up a
full piece hope you enjoyed it careful
of the real Lopez see you soon